et aujourd'hui je te demande et vous à
paris un des papes on est juste en face
du café proche
ces rues au boulevard rochechouart je ne
sais plus on n'est pas loin du sacré
coeur pour vous parler de ce petit
produit j'ai un produit qui était lancée
par au pot c'est dans la gamme raynaud
on a déjà parlé du réno avec le zoom x
10 en a parlé du réno qui roule le
milieu de gamme et là on parle d'un
produit milieu d'entrée de gamme parce
que du milieu de gamme déjà très bien
dans le milieu de gamme
je peux si vous me suivez celui là c'est
le réno z alors renault a dit les cool
il a plein de bonne qualité il conseille
surtout de qualité en photos aussi et
c'est ce qui fait dire tout l'intérêt de
cette gamme raynaud néanmoins il ya des
coupes franches qui ont été faites pour
sortir un produit intéressant beaucoup
moins chers notamment au niveau ici là
de la petite caméra ce que je propose
c'est que on avait rencontré chef de
produit déchets au pot comme ça ils
croient tous nous dire on sera tous il
ya des trucs bien et tout moins bien on
découvre et on en reparle
[Musique]
ça m'a très bien
ouais ouais enfin parler fort il ya
beaucoup de monde dans la rue évoque le
bruit des voitures qui passent c'est ça
on est là tous que le nouveau fort et
nous aide c'est ça alors j'aimerais
comprendre le truc avant même de parler
du produit
c'est quoi la volonté c'est d'ouvrir la
gamme raynaud vraiment cette gamme
lâcher ou pour vous allez bosser et là
c'est vraiment maintenant c'est une
gamme complète puisqu'on a le grand
frère qui est le rideau une fois nice
ensuite on a le frère du milieu qui le
rhino et le petit frère du groupe qui
arrive maintenant leur hymne aux aides
bon
on s'adresse à un public plus large
maintenant avec l'om a repris la main
c'est bien c'est bien placé par rapport
à l'aspect offre de téléphone là sur ce
petit dernier on à 349 euros
il ya passé retard devrait être très
intéressant au niveau dizaines et j'en
vois qui conserve comme un petit peu le
il a les codes du réno les codes vérité
seulement avec les capteurs qui sont
intégré dans la coque à l'arrière la
petite perle ici qui comme sur le rhino
vient protéger les capteurs contre les
rayures alors par contre on a un coloris
assez sympa qui nous vaut lui rigolo ça
existe en
de couleur noire ou celui ci
nous rappelons tous les goûts et
d'imposer classique
quelque chose d'un peu plus
alors c'est quoi la dn 2 à 2 parce que
moi ce que j'ai compris quand tu auras
effectivement qu'à l'aréna zoom x 10
tout il va t sur une gamme qui est fait
effectivement pour avoir une qualité
photo au top
ouais retrouve avec le reno qui est bien
qui marche très bien on n'a pas le même
jour 60 mais qui marche bien quant à
elle et d'aileron de requin
là tu arrives et tu te retrouves avec
une encoche goutte d'eau qui marche
mais du coup tu dis as qu'ont parfois un
peu la donne de cette gamme en fait pas
complètement après chevaux faut quand
même qu'ils aient une différenciation
entre entre les trois grammes mais c'est
vrai que les le rhino alonso fadil on
proposait avoir ce côté un peu plus
innovants on va dire parce que ça fait
aussi partie de la gamme et non halal à
côté innovation avec un plein écran et
la caméra et tractable
après c'est vrai que là on
[Musique]
regarde comme certaines choses de la
gamme en termes de photos notamment
attendent une qualité photo
ouais je garde les mêmes capteurs
l'arrière par contre c'est vrai que j'ai
plus le petit système mécanique à
l'arrière sa carrière principale c'est
là c'est la seule qui ici là en dessous
40 millions pixels +5
c'est là sony sony a mis de l'avant par
contre à l'avant par contre j'ai trente
deux mégapixels au lieu de 16 sur les
camry no mais on met plus l'accent sur
le côté celle fissures sur ce modèle là
ok on a aussi une grosse batterie
oui j'ai eu l'énorme peut-être mis 35
millions perd donc très bonne autonomie
c'est vrai que c'est quelque chose qui
est beaucoup recherché aujourd'hui quand
même brillé gentil sèche ouais et
indiquées de presse de cette sortie son
stéréo
ce qui est plutôt pas mal aussi son
stéréo par le bas ou leur talent
métalleux les deux c'est le haut et le
bas qui met au raifort et ben ok cool et
on a trouvé plus chirac aussi on a
la radio fm si jamais un rat qui fait du
coup c'est avec des écouteurs
représentatif en dentelle
ces camions et pc ok cool toujours de
l'écran amoled
oui très bonne qualité avec c'est quand
on est étudiant en garde du amoled parce
qu'on veut vraiment garder une superbe
qualité c'est pour des personnes qui
vont consommer du multimédia what i call
you parleurs stéréo d'un grand écran les
gars c'est le jeu et film effectivement
savent maintenant on regarde beaucoup
netflix ou canal sûr c'est sur son
téléphone c'est quand même un gros plus
avoir les moyens
voilà c'est en fait dans cette gamme de
prix a peu de constructeurs qu'ils
proposent par cinq sens
ouais carrément vraiment par contre en
terme de deux perfs sur du jeu tu vas
pas pouvoir utiliser des jeux qui vont
consomme énormément aujourd'hui forte
n'est peut-être pas faites pas forte
mètres mais
je ne peux pas me fait toujours tourner
du pib géogiens valeur sans problème en
ce sens qu on a aussi des optimisations
software justement sur ces jeux qui vont
permettre de booster les performances
parce qu'il sera négatif tu n'essaies 1
et lyon médias jacques p 90 qui abritait
on va dire l'équivalent c'est un petit
peu en tout dix neuf des 27 100 ghz de
sequans com est un peu et c'est au
dessus par contre 2,660 royaume de
performance donc c'est ça reste quand
même un bon bain un téléphone
performante utilisée que kaka durable
peut-être giga de ram et 128 go de
stockage d'armes extensible 128 le sidf
non extensible effectivement qu'elle est
double sim et s'adresse à qui ce
smartphone a dit hun sen qui veulent un
smartphone apple polyvalent avec de
bonnes photos et un décor qualité il
s'agit d'évoquer pris un petit prix
effectivement et puis enfin c'est
vraiment téléphone bien équilibré il a
aussi la charge rapide sans a pas parlé
ouais donc j'ai comme une grosse
dépendant des performances très bonnes
globalement très bonnes photos et puis
grosse batterie ce qui va répondre à
tous les besoins de
du quotidien folha polyvalent panon
polyvalence et pour un public jeune mais
qui veut aussi peut-être acheter quelque
chose d'un peu plus qualitative que
juste un téléphone à 150 250 euros là
j'ai quand même vraiment quelque chose
de bien pour 350 euros
ok est ce que vous êtes chez vous
aujourd'hui vous êtes arrivé en france
l'année dernière
ouais au carrousel du louvre alors j'ai
c'est à dire en termes de ferme de bain
en termes d'avancées en termes
d'avancées on voit que les gammes
s'étoffent avec la gamme raynaud qui
arrivent il ya quelques temps oui ben
alors aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'on a on
a déjà une offre qui est beaucoup plus
variés on aimerait beaucoup plus
diversifiée on a une gamme plus étendue
on propose des produits voilà pour à peu
près tous les ports tous les
portefeuilles
aujourd'hui avec des belles choses dans
chaque segment
[Musique]
poursuit sa route en europe pour
l'instant ça une communication qui s'est
fait comme plus visibles avec roland
garros notamment l'arrière doter
d'autres compétitions sportives a comme
donc bye à wimbledon hier express master
donc on reste dans l'esprit tennis a
quand même il ya à dire avec lamborghini
on a aussi des choses
oui oui un partenaire sur le finepix
phoenix lamborghini quand il était très
gentil
je me rappelle en participant à
certaines courses j'ai pu nous en tête
mais voit la super trophée aussi parce
qu'il a trop fait aussi c'est sympa
voilà c'est donc au nom de vraiment ça
te rend bien et puis on est on est assez
content nos partenaires sont contents
aussi wise est ce qu'il va y avoir des
notes smartphone au sérieux garde toi
comme le n 10 qui arrivé l'année
dernière alors que vous avez travaillé
sur cette typologie de haut de gamme les
regards dans la logique forcément fine
de fans c'est une une des séries damart
donc à une des gammes de la marque donc
a priori il y aura il y aura des
nouveautés pour l'instant j'ai rien par
contre de donner à manger désolé j'ai
pas d'infos officielles auxquelles voilà
dans la logique des choses
il devrait avoir une issue de forcément
ouais vous avez peut-être suivi
récemment l'actualité au pot a
officialisé une technologie qui la
caméra sous l'écran donc au lieu d'avoir
un système de caméra rétractable là ça
sera carrément directement intégrés sous
l'écran qui permettra à tous de gagner
en place en séries 2 et qui sera intégré
dans quel typologie de gamme ça je ne
sais pas si c'est encore sur la techno
meilleures d'après le produit le mode
nuit tu as avec la sony gamme x86
cellier des arcades pixels en mode c'est
un pixel notamment et après c'est aussi
un mode vraiment d'optimisation on a
vraiment logicielles logiciels aussi
voilà qui permet d'avoir ma nuit parce
qu'on n'avait pas sur le prédécesseur
qui était lui règle 17 neo
oui là maintenant le propos sont simone
elle aussi
ces sons deviennent différentes pour toi
la gamme rx comme avec leurs enseignants
c'est un peu le successeur mais c'est
vrai que maintenant ça s'appelle rhinau
et voilà ça va comme ses nouvelles
gammes la série ax est amené à
disparaître
par contre ce qui est se différencie de
la gamme à ax welch et au pot qui elle a
eu ni fair game un peu différente
effectivement ok bon bah merci beaucoup
merci on trouve à partir du 10 juillet
au tarif de 349 euros un puits pour lé
lien comme d'habitude regardez ce qu'ils
font tous partie cool merci merci salut
c'est tout pour ce produit aujourd'hui
malheureusement je peux partir avec
je ne peux pas partager ne peut plus
articulé je ne peux pas partir avec
on en reparle d'ici quelques jours je
vous invite à rester connectés à vous
abonner comme ça vous saurez tout moi je
trouve très intéressant c'est au pot
raynaud z plutôt bien et trop riche en
bonnes promesses en tout cas c'est un
bon rapport qualité prix c'est un bon
compromis
parce que vous pensez que vous en bas en
commentaire est ce que ça pourrait vous
tentez qu'est ce que vous en pensez
par rapport au reste de la gamme par
rapport au reyno par rapport au reyno
zoom x 10 est ce que ce produit là vous
paraît intéressant oui nos enfants
comment vous de marquer tout ça et puis
bien sûr on reste connectés
voilà où fait des gros becs vous et à
très bientôt
non